hi everyone
welcome to our talk on switching from
dynamodb to cloud bigtable and cloud
spanner
we had a lot of learnings and we had a
lot of fun when we ended up migrating
from aws to google cloud and we'd like
to share our experiences with you
my name is venkatesh ramaswamy i work
for sharechat
and my co-presenter is vishal perpia who
works for cloud cover
we'll talk a little bit about who we are
and what we do and
fundamental reasons as to why you would
choose a migration
some of the choice of database and
decisions that we went
we ended up going through some of the
key design and architectural principles
as well
some of the details around data
migration batch and stream processing
would also be discussed
we will delve a little bit on
performance and audit and why those are
important
and finally end up with some other
learnings that we had through the
process
a little bit on who we are and what we
do
let me talk about chat chat the company
that i work for we were founded in 2015
and our latest series d funding was led
by twitter in august of 2019
we are india's homegrown and one of the
largest social media platforms out there
where we don't offer english as an
option
as of latest we have about 150 million
active users on our website
we exist because there is a fundamental
disconnect between
the choice that a lot of users in india
want versus what's available up there
if you see the users in tier 2 and
tier 3 series in india a lot of them are
not comfortable
in conversing in english because that's
not their native language
so we give them the language language of
their choice
that they could use to end up
interacting conversing and sharing
social media posts with people around
them
very recently we also launched moj a
short video app
that we will spend a little bit of
limelight towards the end
of this presentation i'll now hand it
over to vishal to talk about him
and his company thanks venkatesh so i'm
vishal i'm the ceo and co-founder for
cloud cover
we are a premier partner with google
cloud and we specialize
in moving companies like sharechat from
one cloud to the other or from their
data center to the cloud
our core focus is on agile enterprises
and scale startups
and we use a lot of new technology
including cloud native tech
in order to make that happen with devops
and data engineering
so i'm going to talk specifically about
what we did
with sharechat and at a very high level
it always looks
really easy on both aws and google cloud
you
effectively have an app a service and a
database but
as we all know the devil is in the
details
and i'm going to hand it back to
venkatesh to give you a little bit of
insight
as to the unique challenges that we
faced in this particular migration
thanks michelle as we are done looking
at what you need to do
when you move from one cloud system to
the other you have to look at the
fundamental challenges that you would
encounter
in our case we were on ecs and we wanted
to be completely on gke
when we would finish the migration
process
cloudwatch was our choice for all the
logging and monitoring on aws
on google it would have to be
stackdriver logging and monitoring
with the keynote that we would need 100
of it to be available
on day one for our observability
requirements
on aws we were completely on elastic
cache using redis as a storage engine
on google cloud we would want to end up
being on managed redis and even though
they were
sort of almost the same company it is
not exactly apples to apples and that's
something that we were
we had to contend with now data
migration is a very key piece
of the entire process and we were
sure that we had to need 100 of our data
even when a single user had to be
migrated over
from aws to google cloud ultimately we
needed a service mesh integration
to get better insights into our
inter-service dependencies
and we have to do all of this with zero
downtime
when you start your migration and get
through the process
it's like drinking from a fire hose we
hope to share with you some of our key
learnings some of our key challenges
through the next set of slides to make
sure that you are not in the same
situation
and you do a much better job with all
the learnings and challenges that we
ended up going through
so let's fundamentally ask ourselves why
should we migrate
let me walk you through some of the
thoughts that we had which started at
around
mid of last year where we were hitting
limitations of scale
with dynamodb now we partially solved
them through the use of tax
but they were just not good enough we
were still hitting a lot of challenges
during peak times so when we ended up
looking deeper into what we had to do
we came to the conclusion along with
consultation from aws that we had to
rewrite a lot of our key and core
systems
now in that situation we wondered was
there another option
was there something we could do from the
ground up and should we look at
moving to another cloud provider and
ultimately the set of changes that we
need to do
were pretty dramatic to begin with the
other key
factor was that we had to save costs and
this was extremely important
given the kind of scale and the kind of
traffic that we had
we also were looking for a very key and
strategic partner
for our long-term set of challenges that
we would ultimately end up encountering
and we had very unique use cases that we
were encountering
month after month ultimately we needed a
platform for innovation
and that's why we looked across the
board and google cloud
came out thoughts in our evaluation as
to the platform of choice
let me give you a little bit of the
stats and go over some of the key stats
on our existing system using dynamodb we
had
a total of about 200 and odd tables that
we had to migrate and about 80 terabytes
of data
as an example a single table had close
to about 17 secondary indexes
obviously not extremely optimized but
something that we had to account for
when we end up doing the migration
at peak our total read units were
at about 5 million qps and that was a
lot of data that we had to contend and
make sure that
we don't take a hit and ultimately our
read and write latencies were
at the order of about six milliseconds
and that's
a very critical number that we could not
compromise on
let's start with the choice of databases
and ultimately here's our learning
right for any migration you have to make
sure that the data considerations
are taken care of from day one you solve
for the data
and i can almost guarantee that the bulk
of your problems
and your pain points will be
automatically taken care of so there's
one learning that you want to take away
it probably is that now
we had a polyglot set up in our systems
we had a lot of dynamodb
a lot of redis [ __ ] cassandra elastic
s3 you name it we had it
and we also needed a nosql that would
support secondary nexus
so we had fundamentally four choices
that we could end up choosing from
choice number one we could go with a
single cloud managed database
you know life is easy we could just make
one choice and move on
choice number two we could still make a
single choice but this time we would
choose a self-managed database
completely
to be taken care from rn choice number
three would be a
hybrid solution but optimized for cost
and ultimately the fourth choice
would be another hybrid solution but
optimized for long-term maintainability
looking at option one and option two
it's a very clear choice between
choosing a single database that's
provided by cloud that's cloud native
which is very easy to migrate but would
be extremely complex for some use cases
where you don't need all that
functionality
or would you want to go self-managed
where you would take on the burden of
maintaining
all the different databases you would
have hired experts but now in my opinion
a self-managed database actually
nullifies the impact and the benefits of
why you would actually choose cloud in
the first place
it's useful for a lot of situations but
not in our use case
if you look at option three one of the
things we could do
was for all our index and secondary
index needs we
could choose and store them in a
database that actually supported that
in this case that would be cloud spanner
and all the raw data
the data on the leaf nodes we could
store it in a database that didn't
require
any special indexing requirements which
would be cloud big table
so the data in a single table would be
split across two tables
this would make reads and writes a
little interesting
and would require applications or at
least a layer
to handle those reads and writes
interestingly
on the on the app side of things instead
of the database side of things
let's look at option four which is
ultimately what we ended up choosing
this is getting the database to do what
it's really good at
so we ended up using cloud bigtable for
all our
single index database requirements table
requirements and storage requirements
and we used cloud spanner for all the
requirements where you needed more than
a single index
so this allowed us to end up using the
database for what
it was built for for what it was really
good at and taking
and moving the burden from the
application owners
to the databases and leveraging them for
what they are really good at
we'll talk a little bit about the key
design and architectural principles for
that i want to have vishal come
and spend some time thanks venkatesh
so after we helped sharechat to figure
out which options worked best for their
specific use case
um we had to then get into the actual
design
of how we would make these work and how
we would actually enact the
migration itself the concept that
made sense for us over here was to use a
data abstraction layer
now a data abstraction layer is a fairly
common design pattern
in in software engineering and it also
takes the guys of something like a
middleware
in the case of sharechat they were
already using libraries internally to
kind of obfuscate dynamodb
and provide that functionality to the
application so we wanted to take
advantage of that
the traditional approach would have had
the data abstraction layer live
inside of the service so literally
inside the code
but because we were moving to kubernetes
we had the opportunity
of using a sidecar approach to make the
same thing happen
and this gave us a few really key
benefits
that we would have otherwise not been
able to get this modified sidecar
approach effectively
took the shape of a database driver that
ran as a sidecar process
and allowed us to do things like
connection pooling for the pod
we were also able to do a single driver
for multiple different kinds of
languages and just have a different
library that would interact with it over
grpc and this
obviously gave us a dramatic performance
increase in terms of the
the kind of code that we were running
because we wrote everything in goal
and it also allows us to in the future
potentially change
the database redirections and this
pattern works so well that we're
actually going to open source this with
google as well
the critical piece over here though was
that sharechat didn't need to change
anything inside their application layer
at all they just need to swap out the
library that was being used to access
the database and this gave us
an enormous benefit in terms of the
speed with which
we could actually make this migration
occur
so i'm going to talk about that
migration in a little bit more detail
this was obviously a fairly gargantuan
task as you saw but the earlier slides
that venkates showed you
um we were talking about a substantial
number of both tables
as well as data and in order for us to
be able to move this over from aws to
google
in a repeatable and reliable manner we
had to use
a multi-stage process so the three
phases that we ended up with
effectively looked like this we had a
starting
with a batch of an upload of all of the
data
until a specific point in time and at
the moment that we actually
started that dump of data from dynamodb
we
also started inserting all mutations
that occurred to the dynamodb tables
into pub sub we were going to use that
in t1
which was basically after we were done
with the load we wanted to be able to
play back all the changes that happened
to the database
after we had loaded that point in time
snapshot
following that and this is the the most
crucial phase
when we were actually sort of in sync we
wanted to be able to start streaming
data
directly from aws to google and uh this
was probably one of the most complicated
parts of the entire system because we
couldn't use pubsub to do this we had to
build our own
system to enable that kind of streaming
from dynamodb
directly into both cloud bigtable and
cloud spanner
so let's talk about the batch processing
so we took
exports of the table data from dynamodb
which ended up inside s3
and we would basically watch and consume
those and stuff them into an sqs queue
that would be processed by ec2 instances
that would both uh compress and transfer
that over to gcs
on the google side we were watching and
consuming those buckets
through cloud functions that were
triggering uh individual
dags inside of airflow which was running
on cloud composer
that would run on top of a data flow
multiple jobs to both
uh load data into cloud spanner as well
as cloud bigtable simultaneously
and this obviously was dependent upon
the configurations that we had as to
which table
went into which system on the basis of
where the indexes were
so all of the tables that had multiple
indexes would end up in cloud spanner
and all the tables that had single
indexes would end up in cloud bigtable
and give us better performance the load
process itself
was also extremely complicated um as you
can imagine
firstly we're trying to take data that's
inside a nosql system and put it inside
a sql system in the case of cloud
spanner
that required us to actually add missing
columns when we
detected them inside the data that we
were getting
because a lot of this was legacy data
there weren't very
stable schemas and taking advantage of
nosql allows you to effectively create
keys and values
as you see fit well that information
wasn't present
when we dumped the data um in some kind
of format that would allow us to create
the tables
um before we did the transfer so we had
to actually do that on the fly
so the code that we wrote inside
dataflow would actually process
all of those individual rows and add the
appropriate tables
column families and missing columns as
required
we also had a dead letter pattern that
dealt with rejected records and allowed
us to retry them after we had made the
appropriate changes to either the data
type
or the schema itself
once we were done with that initial
transfer we had to switch to doing the
stream processing
this is where it started getting really
interesting so in order to make this
happen
we used a system on dynamodb called
dynamodb streams
now what that does is it effectively
puts all the mutations that are
happening inside dynamodb
into a stream that can be consumed and
it retains the data for about 24 hours
the lambda functions that get triggered
on the back of that had to be configured
because it got really expensive really
fast
so we set those up so that they would
take batches of 10 000 records
in five minute intervals and push those
over to some custom code that we wrote
on the google side running on compute
engine written in golang
that would allow us to both push the
data in real time
into cloud spanner and cloud bigtable
depending upon the configurations that
we had in place
and this is really what allowed us to do
this um
we tried to use uh pub sub and and there
were multiple
concerns that we ran into with that some
of them were latest
latency related and some of them were
related to ordering of the records in
order to make sure that it was going
into the database systems at the right
time
as you can imagine latency and
performance is absolutely key over here
and we actually built a whole bunch of
interesting code to be able to manage
any kind of breaks that might occur in
the stream itself
so after we were done with that transfer
it fell to uh
our team to make sure that venkatesh was
happy with the outcome and that meant
making sure that the data
actually matched born both systems and
that's where this comes in
bank addiction thanks michelle
performance and audit
are two understated steps in any
migration process
they never get the due diligence and i
want to talk a little bit about
what we did to end up focusing on these
two aspects
so you always start with data that's
publicly available right it's great to
have
data which is a starting point but you
make sure that you verify them
um so what we did was to set up a dummy
setup in our stating environment so in
this example that i have for you
we had a 40 node cluster for a real
table called tag posts
which was set up on spanner which had
about 160
gb of data uh with about five indexes
and we
hammered it um with a redirect ratio of
a four is to one
this allowed us to see how this banner
table
actually scaled with the amount of
traffic that it was getting and what was
its breaking point
and once you had that the next key part
and the most important part
is to try the same in production and the
reason for that is
your physical setup for staging and
production are going to be fundamentally
different
and you do this and you rinse and repeat
for most of the key flows and the key
tables
that you would expect to hit a lot of
traffic during normal and during peak
times and this would give you
a lot of comfort when you turn on the
migration step
completely onto one side
the two different audit parts that are
important for any migration are
for one for streaming and the other
which we will talk about in the next
slide
for streaming it's extremely important
for us to make sure
that the data has been caught up from
the source
and the system of truth to the new
system that is under test in this case
aws was the source of truth and google
cloud would be the system under test
so the graph that we have in front of
you was uh data that we got from influx
which we were ending up inserting into
and visualizing grafana
so you see that initially at time t
equal to zero you have
about 18 to 19 hours of lag and
ultimately it takes about six hours for
the data to actually catch up
and get close down to zero as much as
possible again
you do this for your key metrics for
your key tables and
these are extremely important to have at
your disposal
to make sure that your business metrics
are doing as well as
your system metrics now looking at
audit for data consistency the way we
did this
was to make sure that we replayed the
events that were happening on aws
on google cloud and did a simple json
diff of the two response objects that we
got back
and if there were any differences we
would end up logging that so the values
that you see here
are real values that we got when we
initially started out our migration
processes
and this allowed us to make sure that we
we fix this we take care of this we
handle this
before we shift even the first user over
and that gave us the confidence to go
extremely confidently to business and
say you know what
the system is as good as as the business
metrics and we should not see
any perceptible impact on users as they
end up moving from one system to the
other
and ultimately i want to focus a little
bit on learnings but before that
i want to start off with a small story
uh which started at around
the first week of july not too long ago
uh where we launched
our short video app called much um which
took just about 30 hours
from ideation to the actual launch um
and guess what we were all ready um
google cloud was ready for us in terms
of scale in terms of the kind of
traffic that we were expecting around
the same time
because of geopolitical reasons our
traffic on the sharechat app
also um went astronomical we went to
almost 3x 4x the amount of data that we
were
typically used to and we didn't even
blink an eye we were able to
horizontally scale
with zero to minimal code changes um
close enough about a week from then
we made the decision to move um all of
the traffic for mulch which was
quite a bit onto singapore and all this
really happened behind the scenes
seamlessly thanks to the amazing support
from google that we ended up receiving
care for the minimal changes that we had
to do on the dns
entries we really didn't have much in
terms of challenges that we faced during
that
shift over and ultimately you know it's
it's kudos to everybody who has been
involved
in this and i wanted to use this as the
poster child for the benefits that we
have gotten
uh just three months after the migration
process
and ultimately the learnings from the
migration itself um i think it's
important to know that
the migration or any migration of this
nature is not going to be a linear path
you could plan for all you want you
could build all the contingencies in
place you would still end up
encountering things
of the unknown nature and you just have
to fight your way through it
but what's very key and important is the
top-down ownership
and the commitment that you need to have
to make sure to get through all these
challenges that have come your way
and sign up for you know long weekends
and nights that will
ultimately um be the outcome um
solve your db choices first extremely
important right i've mentioned this
before i'm going to keep mentioning this
your data is going to be the ultimate
decider of how good your migration
process is your data
doesn't get moved correctly you could
have any number of challenges
even with all the computes in place even
with all the scalability inputs
and then ultimately separate out your
migration and your optimization tasks a
lot of the people who want to end up
doing one step of the migration process
then ending up putting an optimization
step on top of that
it doesn't work very well in fact it's
it's a it's chaotic it's extremely
disastrous um we didn't do it and we
would never do it even if you have to
redo this
all over again there's a lot of
learnings but the key part is separate
them out
make sure that you focus on the
migration if you have cost concerns
talk to google talk to your cloud
provider i'm sure they'll have a path
forward for you guys
and ultimately work as a single team
folks i can't emphasize this enough we
had
a lot of different parties associated
with this we had
developers we had the google pso team we
had actual google engineers from spanner
from big table
from from core engineering teams we had
um
our set of consultants we had cloud
cover who was our partner in crime
and we worked as a single unit which
means that if i had feedback to give i
would not just give it to my folks i
would give it to everybody
um so finally i want to thank all these
people involved
um an amazing set of
aligned work amazingly focused set of
people that were involved in this
process
it would be impossible to end up
thanking everybody that made this
possible
but i still want to give out my
heartfelt thanks from both me and vishal
for making this a reality thank you
folks thank you for everything
you